une croissance moyenne de 100 % entre
2016 et 2017 c'est le résultat du
dirigeant saint quentinois yves ten
spécialiste en prise de participations
dans les sociétés il est à la tête d'un
groupe de six entreprises spécialisées
dans la restauration et la communication
oui je sens depuis quelques temps un
début de reprise principalement liée à
une accélération des prises de décision
par nos donneurs d'ordres et l'autre
cette accélération de décision est
propice à avoir filmé en plus de projets
autre entreprise à coignières cet
atelier propose de créer une stratégie
de publicité création de supports
d'affichage ou de logos alexandre david
réalise avec ses cinq collaborateurs
près de 500000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires
la relance économique est perçu à
travers ses carnets de commandes en ou
sur 2018 on vise à une augmentation du
chiffre d'affaires de 30%
ça va se traduire par notamment
effectivement l'envol d'un commercial
l'acquisition de nouveaux secteurs
d'activité on a investi dernièrement
envoyé de nouvelles machines dans lequel
ont investi pour créer plus rapidement
et livrer plus rapidement nos clients
donc on compte aussi sur ça pour aller
chercher un levier de croissance
du côté de soap emea spécialisée dans
les essais industriels dans
l'aéronautique le ferroviaire ou encore
le nucléaire
l'année 2010 est a été stable en terme
de résultats mais les signes de reprise
ne sont pas évidents ce qui est
important pour nous c'est les nouveaux
avions et nouveau type d'avion qui vont
sortir ou les nouvelles centrales
nucléaires ou les nouvelles technologies
ça c'est notre métier est aujourd'hui
effectivement il n'y a pas de nouveauté
dans ces mythes dans ces mondes
dans lequel nous évoluons en nous
investissant à l'étranger nous venons de
racheter un laboratoire en angleterre on
s'interroge sur d'autres pays européens
voir sur d'autres pays en dehors de
l'europe pour pouvoir effectivement les
chercher des relais de croissance que
nous ne trouvons pas suffisamment en
france croissance investissement et
emplois la reprise varie en fonction du
secteur d'activité
les chefs d'entreprise sont unanimes sur
le besoin de visibilité sur le long
terme